it's pretty rare to have a conversation
about education policy in which the word
technology isn't used at some point
occasionally in the administrative sense
as a way to make education more
efficient but mostly in the classroom
sense helping kids learn which gets us
to Salman Khan he's a former hedge fund
manager turned educator as the founder
and sole faculty member of the Khan
Academy it started as a tutoring service
for his cousin's on YouTube it's become
a library of thousands of instructional
videos on topics from basic arithmetic
to organic chemistry to the French
Revolution with financial backing from
among others the Gates Foundation Sal
Khan good to have you with us great to
be here how exactly did you wind up
putting videos on YouTube I was a little
dismissive of it at first I didn't think
YouTube was for serious mathematics I
thought it was more for for dogs on
skateboards or whatever else but but I
decided to give it a shot and people all
over the world started watching them and
you know some of them would say hey this
helped me out an exam but someone would
say hey this helped me not drop out of
high school or this helped me get into
the the school that I wanted to get into
so it became a pretty exciting thing to
work on what's the education problem
though that you think this technology
can solve it's a pretty straightforward
problem is is that everyone learns at
different paces and right now everyone's
forced to go at the same pace and it's a
more serious problem than just people
being bored or people being lost in one
classroom what happens when everyone
moves at the same pace is you and I are
in an exam or you know we're learning a
basic subject I I don't get five percent
of the subject you don't get twenty
percent of the subject the whole class
moves on to a more advanced subject I
have a five percent gap you have a
20-percent gap those gaps build up over
time and it pretty much guarantees that
most students by the time to get to
algebra calculus have so many of these
gaps that no matter how hard they try
they just can't understand what's going
on so what we're trying to address is
every student can go at their own pace
make sure that they master something
before moving on and when you do that
then those gaps shouldn't shouldn't
happen it's an accumulation of failure
right isn't that your friend yeah I
would say it's accumulation of gaps and
and and actually the failure thing is
another interesting you know right now
when you take an assessment to test it
in school you get a label you get an a B
or C or D you know the eight kids kind
of feel good about themselves they get
self-confidence
be students are a little bit neutral you
get a CD or F it's not viewed as hey you
didn't understand thirty percent why
don't you go and try to learn a little
bit better to do it as you're not so
smart don't try to become an engineer
physicist where do you fit in though
where does Khan Academy fit in and the
large application of technology to
education how do you slide in there for
a while whenever people talk about
technology and education they've just
been talking about putting computers or
iPads whatever in a room and and hoping
something good happens even when there
was something to do on a computer it was
always viewed as separate from the core
curriculum it was viewed separate of
what normally goes on in a math class
what we're saying is now we can actually
use technology we can use these videos
we can use this software to allow every
student to work at their own pace it's
not an either/or the proposition anymore
but there's always this debate if do you
do more of the core skills or do more if
the projects and the investigations
we're saying you can do both you can use
the technology to hand a lot of the core
skills free up a lot of the teachers
time to do more of the the human
interactions for the price of a login
right you either login through Facebook
or Google you get access to all these
things is there a thought in your mind
of somehow making people pay for this we
want at some point be sustainable as a
not-for-profit but we want all of this
material to be one hundred percent
accessible by everyone so on the web and
and our core tools will always be free
right right now nothing on our radar is
a non-free I guess it's a simple answer
so what's the next step for the Khan
Academy right now we have about two
million students a month who use our
site on a regular basis we want to start
leveraging them so that they can help
each other so if you're in a classroom
your teacher knows that you need help
and if you're not in the classroom or if
you need to supplement to a classroom
maybe one of the other community members
of the Khan Academy can tutor you or
help you out or get you past your hurdle
Salman Khan he's the founder of the Khan
Academy thanks a lot great thanks